- Our next guest, y'all,
is a perfect person
to shine a light on For Giving Tuesday.
With more than 17 million
followers on TikTok alone,
he is blown up on social media
with videos of him
surprising complete strangers
with gestures of love and appreciation.
This summer, I teamed up with
him for one of these moments.
- Oh my gosh, nice to see you.
We're surprising you with Vegas.
I don't know if you wanna
come to Vegas to see the show.
(shouting)
Hope you love the show!
Ah, it was so cool to be a part of.
Let's welcome Zach, known
on TikTok as MD Motivator.
Welcome to the show.
- Thank you for having me.
- Absolutely, I love,
I'm obviously, you know,
I'm a fan of what you do, but
how did you get into this?
- [Zach] So the name on social media
stands for MD Motivator,
which means Medical Doctor Motivator
'cause during the COVID,
COVID and the pandemic,
I was in medical school
in Sydney, Australia.
- Yeah.
- And when I say the
pandemic, a lot of people
really lacked connection and felt alone
and during that time I had a con,
a combination of things
that happened to me.
I went through a six year
relationship breakup.
Medical school was challenging.
I had an ACL surgery.
There wasn't anything particular-
- Oh God, you didn't get a break.
- [Zach] But it was just a breaking point.
- Yeah.
- And it was finally a time in my life
where I saw a blank slate.
Who am I?
What's my purpose?
What makes me happy?
And I just didn't feel,
I was really in a hole and
I had no one to turn to.
So I started making videos
to find a friend to create connection.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And that's how this journey started
and I started making
blindfolded hugging videos
where I would hug strangers
because one night
when I was in Sydney,
Australia in medical school,
in the middle of the
night, I went for a walk.
I didn't wanna tell my roommate
what I was going through
and I sat there in the rain
and these two women in
their late thirties,
they came up to me and they're
like, "What's going on?"
And I was like hysterically
crying at the time
and I said nothing
and they just sat there in the wet cement
and they listened to me
and the power of just
having a stranger hear me
made me wanna do that for others,
so that's why I started
blindfolded hugging strangers
if they're going through
depression or heartbroken
or felt empty or missing someone.
I just want-
- Yeah.
- [Zach] 'Cause that pivoted my life
and I had never been able
to reach them ever again.
- Wow.
- So if you're listening out
there in Sydney, Australia,
I love you.
You've changed my life forever
and I just wanted to be the same for them.
- [Kelly] Oh my, what a magical start?
I'm not-
- Yeah.
- I didn't know that's how it started.
- That's how it started.
- Well what, what was your first video?
- My first video was a
poster in September of 2021.
It said, "Your vaccination status
won't change how much I love you."
- [Kelly] Ugh.
- [Zach] And what-
- [Kelly] That was a huge, yeah.
- [Zach] And this video
wasn't about the V word
as much as it was about
unconditional love.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- At a time when we really
needed the connection.
- Absolutely.
- So it was very polarizing,
but at that point it wasn't
about the polarization.
I just wanted to bring people together.
- [Kelly] Yeah, absolutely.
- Yeah, that's how it started.
- [Kelly] Love is love, I love that.
Well, these moments
really are so powerful,
so just check out how it can
have a trickle down effect.
Watch this.
- How are you?
- My daughter was the one
with the little pompoms on her head
that came up and hugged you today,
so I just wanted to say thank you
because she's really been
struggling with depression
and you kind of made her
day today, so thank you.
- She gave a really tight hug
and she said, "I needed this."
I didn't know.
- Yeah.
Thank you so much.
It made a whole difference to her day.
- Like-
(audience applauding)
- You, I, you say something,
I've heard that you say something that is,
it's like your mess
equals the message, right?
- Your mess is your message.
- [Kelly] Yeah, the mess is your message.
I love that.
It's so simple but effective.
- [Zach] It is.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And you find your purpose in like
the things you're going through, right?
And like, although you don't want,
you're going through something,
you don't ever wanna lose hope
and to know that what I went through
allowed me to be able to share that.
Whether it's the person in
that video or the daughter
or the people that watch it online
who maybe are going through something
to just know that they're not alone.
- [Kelly] I've seen it several times
and I'm still crying over
it, it's so beautiful.
Just how affected she is and
how much you don't know like
something that you do
might affect somebody else
and impact them in a
negative or positive way.
- [Zach] Yes.
- You know?
- And to be grateful for the
people you have in your life
while you have them, so I was able-
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- Fortunate to bring my mom here today.
- Yeah, Mama.
- This mom right there.
- We got mom in the house.
- If it wasn't for her,
I wouldn't be here,
so everything I've learned
is through my parents,
my mom and my dad, so I'm just so blessed.
- [Kelly] That's very beautiful.
- Thank you.
- And it's grown beyond you.
It's now bigger than you.
- Yeah, it's just, it's,
it's been mind boggling
and then we recently started our own 501C3
called Kindness is Cool.
So we have a charity that
just launched about two months ago.
So we're trying to really scale this
and bring into the school systems and-
- That's amazing.
- [Zach] Do good.
- Yeah and you already have
these sponsors, people you know,
like the networking of that right now-
- You!
- [Kelly] It's like, yeah.
- Having to be on the
show with you right now.
- The networking of that is
so cool and you're able to,
from that one night out there
with those two women that stopped you,
like look at all the beauty
that came out of that.
- And if we were all just
a little more vulnerable,
we'd realize that we can
relate and hopefully empower.
- [Kelly] And a little kinder, yeah.
- A little kinder.
- [Kelly] He is all about
surprising total strangers
with acts of kindness.
Total strangers like our next guest
who's a traffic control
officer in Detroit.
Just look at part of their meeting.
- [Zach] Do you wanna buy this
mystery jersey for a buck?
- Sure.
- [Zach] Yeah.
- I can't on my duty right now.
I wouldn't mind.
- [Zach] Are you from Detroit?
- Yes, I am, born and raised.
- [Zach] Are you a Tigers fan?
- Of course.
Tiger fan?
Yes.
- [Zach] What time do
you work till tonight?
- Oh I'm, oh I'm here
till I think 10 or 11.
We got a lot going on tonight.
Let's cross and Happy
Mothers Day to all the moms.
Have a great day, enjoy your evening.
- [Zach] We wanted to let you know that
you got the thumbs up.
- Oh my God.
Are you serious?
- [Zach] We're going
to the game right now.
You're sitting on, by the dugout.
- Right now?
Is this going to hurt my paycheck?
Am I going to be docked?
- [Zach] And you got 500 bucks.
- Oh,
Are you serious?
- [Zach] It's Mother's Day weekend.
We wanna celebrate a mom.
- You don't even know right now.
- [Zach] I love you.
(audience applauding)
- My gosh, every time.
Let's welcome Lanita, everybody.
(audience cheering)
Oh, it doesn't matter how many
times I watch these videos,
I cry every time.
It's just the shock of it, the surprise,
but what were you thinking in that moment?
- A miracle.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It was a miracle because it, it was,
it, just the way that everything happened.
'cause I, you know, I don't
know if he told you anything,
but I kept trying to send
him away and everything else.
- You're like-
- It was really-
- You're like, I'm working.
- Yes, I'm, you know, not even that,
but it was just a lot going on, so.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- In that moment though,
for, for that $500 to,
to be presented to me,
my son and I had just
prayed the night before
'cause my oldest son who's in college
and paying out of pocket,
you know, he said, "Mom,
I'm not gonna be able to
really help the tuition.
I said, "No, pay your tuition,
don't worry about that.
We are gonna pull it together
and we are just gonna pray."
And we prayed and the next
day that, oh, thank you Lord.
Thank you, Jesus.
I couldn't help, it was a miracle.
I know some people were saying,
"Oh, there's only $500."
But it was a miracle
for me in that moment.
- [Kelly] That's incredible.
I wanna give you a list of
things to pray about for me.
You have a direct line
to God or something.
- [Lanita] Oh, oh. I just,
but it stamped my faith.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- In that, in that moment 'cause I was,
my back was against the wall, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Lanita] Literally
on a wing and a prayer.
- Yeah.
- [Lanita] So just for that to happen
and then he was so persistent.
I mean, I kept trying to send him away.
- [Kelly] Why were you so, why Lanita?
- [Zach] Well, it was Mother's Day week
and we wanted to surprise a mom
and all she was doing the
entire time was blessing moms,
have a Happy Mother's Day
and Happy Mother's Day to
all the moms and I'm like-
- [Kelly] Yeah, thank a mother.
- [Zach] Like, I need
to talk to my superior.
I need to talk to my lieutenant.
I'm like, we're getting you to the game,
- [Kelly] It's gonna happen.
- [Zach] So it didn't
matter about the game,
it was just, we, I
wanted to shine the light
and show her energy
and just her love for people to the world.
- Yeah.
- [Lanita] I didn't know what it meant to,
I mean, I understand what viral means.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But I didn't understand what
it means to really go viral.
- Well, that was just
the beginning for Lanita.
Two days later, she was
invited to another Tigers game
and this time a walk onto the field,
so check out what happened.
This is incredible.
- [Announcer] The people of
Detroit that watched the video
donated an additional $50,000
for you and your family.
Way to go, Detroit.
- Like every time.
- [Lanita] Thank you Lord,
thank you Lord, thank you Lord.
Thank you Lord.
- Like you did not expect,
I didn't expect that
and I was watching and I thought,
well, this has gone viral
so this should be amazing,
but I still didn't expect it.
It was incredible.
- Oh my word, oh my word, oh my word.
- Did you pray for that right before?
'Cause like-
- [Lanita] No.
(audience laughing)
Honestly, and this is
the God honest truth.
Zach, no, nobody really knew
'cause it's embarrassing
when you have a, a debt
that's just way over your head.
So when they, when they
brought the check out
and seen it, it felt like a dream,
so when I lift my hands and
I say, "Thank you Lord."
- You mean it.
- That's why.
- I, oh, with every breath in my body.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Every breath in my body.
- [Kelly] No, I, I do understand that.
I was in debt before
Idol, and then I won Idol
and they was like, you
good, need some money?
I'm like, any amount will do.
- Right.
- So what do y'all wanna
both say to people,
like on Giving Tuesday?
Like what is,
what do you want the message
to be for people out there?
- I think the biggest message too
with the $50,000 that was raised was
there was thousands of strangers online
that took their hard earned
money, put it onto this website,
gave it to me, gave it to her,
thinking it's gonna go to good.
The idea that there's social proof
that people wanna do good.
Oftentimes, we just don't
know where to start.
So put good out into the world
and good always attracts to it.
Be kind, lead with
love, lead with kindness
and you get blessed enough
to be on the Kelly Clarkson Show.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Blessed enough to be a part of your show.
Your show touches so many people, ugh,
and to use the social media
outlet like that for good.
You know, like a lot of us
parents are always like,
ah, get off, get off, get off line.
That's like so good, like
to, to use that outlet.
It's for a good power.
- You know I love you.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
Oh my God.
We are gonna be right
back with What I'm Liking.
I'm just gonna use these
tissues a little more.